good
afternoon I hope this mic is working
welcome to uh the launch event for the
new funding partnership to end polio
once and for all and strengthen Health
Systems everywhere we are now going to
move on to the signing of the board
immediately and then we will have a
picture please go
ahead
thank you very much a few seconds to
take
pictures
thank you very much I would now like to
invite the five Partners on
stage
please take your
seats president I believe you can
already come to the podium since you're
the first
speaker
take a seat take
a thank you president you have the floor
thank you very much dear Bill Gates liba
van Hoya Dr Tedros dear Katherine
Russell the global campaign against
polio shows the power of science but it
also shows the power of our Union
since
1988 when wh launched the global
eradication effort the number of polio
cases has dropped by more than
99% 16 million people have been saved
from
paralysis and polio eradication is now
finally at
hand but the final stretch can be the
most challenging so I glad that today we
are launching a new partnership to get
through this last mile so that Humanity
can wipe polio off the face of Earth
just like we did it with small pox in
the
1970s today the European Union the EI
together with the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation are committing more than one
billion Euro to Global Health efforts
half of this 1 billion Euro will go to
the global polio eradication initiative
de Dr tedras to support the wh in
finishing what you have
started this will cover polio
vaccinations for nearly 370 million
children
annually together we can end the
transmission of wild polio already this
year and defeated completely by the end
of the next decade so let's get it
done the other half of our 1 billion
Euro pledge will be invested in making
Health System
stronger stronger in countries and
regions that needed most for example for
local vaccine production and
Manufacturing we have learned our
lessons from
co9 every continent should be able to
produce the vaccine and medicines it
needs it is a matter of fairness and it
is key to defeat Global Health
threats and this is why our global
gateway investment plan is already
investing in local vaccine production
around the
world global gateway has more than 1
billion euros for Africa's vaccine
manufacturing and the results on the
ground are beginning to show I visited
last year the Madiba vaccine
manufacturing project in dhar it is
progressing well and soon a similar
facility will open in Kigali in
Ronda we are also supporting vaccine
production and Manufacturing at scale in
Latin America and the
Caribbean but it is essential that we
all join forces on this the road to
large scale manufacturing is very
complex it requires factories but also
training of thousands of workers all
across the value chain as well as health
sector
reforms so we need to
partner and we need to keep up the good
work that has begun in the wake of the
pandemic this new partnership of old
friends if I may say so shows that our
focus on global Health
continues together we will will end
polio together we will support all
continents to produce the vaccines and
medicines they
need because it should not matter where
you're born and where you live health is
a universal human right thank you very
much thank you thank thank you very much
president I now invite Mr Bill Gates
co-chair of the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation well good afternoon and uh
thank you uh for coming to recognize
this incredible Milestone I want to
thank uh Ursula vandine and the European
commission and our partners from eiib W
and UNICEF uh who are uh it's all great
they're here today
as was mentioned Humanity has only
eradicated a single disease small poox
uh and that was over 50 years ago but
today we're on the verge of ending
another wild polio
virus wild polio virus which once
paralyzed 7,000 children every week has
only paralyzed nine people this year all
in just two countries Pak pistan and
Afghanistan while wild polio is nearly
gone there are also another 280 children
who've been struck by a different polio
variant uh this
year I visited many of these communities
uh where children are still being
paralyzed by polio and of course in
low-income countries it's a devastating
blow and all the more heartbreaking
because it can be stopped Melinda and I
first started F uh supporting this fight
in
1999 and uh we're as committed today uh
through the Gates Foundation uh to this
cause to ensuring that no child anywhere
in the world faces this
disease our foundation is proud to be
part of this new partnership between the
European commission and the European
Investment Bank the 1.1 billion EUR will
be investing together will protect 370
children against polio every year and
this is a key element of finishing the
job and getting to full
eradication plus uh a lot of these
resources will go to make sure that
cuttingedge life-saving Innovations are
available to people in low and middle
inome
countries too often Health Innovations
get to low-income countries a decade or
two decades after they get to rich
country and a big reason is the lack of
access to financial instruments and
investment with this new financing our
partners will develop more tools that
protect People's Health including
vaccines and Therapeutics and make sure
they're available to everyone who needs
them our foundation is very grateful to
the partners who've made this joint work
possible I especially want to thank Dr
wner Hoyer as he wraps up uh his time at
the eiib as a polio Survivor you
understand the impact of this disease
and as eib president you've stepped up
the bank's commitment not just to polio
but to Global health and development
more
broadly this is the kind of dedication
we need to create a world where no
children are suffering from preventable
diseases I look forward to seeing the
progress will unlock together thank you
thank you I now call Mr van Hoya
president of the European Investment
Bank the floor is
yours thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen thank you for being with us
today for announcing a groundbreaking
collaboration in the global fight
against
polio today we have a great
opportunity write together the final
chapter in the history of
polio and eradicate this disease
forever I thank our partners for their
fantastic cooperation I thank first of
all our
teams at the European commission At The
Gates Foundation wh and
dib that work is not done done by the
presidents or
CEOs but I particular would like to to
thank OA
fine Bill Gates Katherine Russell and
tedos Aram gabrius my good old friend
and he's doing much better than a couple
of weeks ago in New York I'm happy to
see this and uh we have now developed
also a very very close cooperation with
UNICEF and that makes me particularly
happy in particular when we talk about
polio and
children we have achieved a lot so far a
large part of the world is basically poo
free cases are low but big risks remain
especially in vulnerable
countries until this spreading goes on
somewhere else we risk to see emerging
waves of the
disease and just last year polio
reemerged in New York
city so it does does make a lot of sense
to focus on
eradication as an investment with a very
strong case and a historical opportunity
for
Humanity we need a last push because
eradication is not an easy feat Poli
cases have gone down massively in the
last decades from the hundreds of
thousands in the 1980s to only a few in
2022 we're now meters away from the top
of a very steep Mountain
but this is of course like always the
most challenging part to
climb it is the part where all strengths
and skills are needed this is the part
that can be won through focus and
perseverance that's why I'm proud
and happy about this partnership it
shows that we can reach
eradication putting together financing
philanthropy
multilateralism
policy
and a shared
Vision at EI we are proud to partner
with great and committed Partners like
the Gates Foundation wh UNICEF and of
course the European commission thanks to
the commission's support the European
Investment Bank will be able to provide
more than 1 billion euros on new
Innovative financing to increase
immunization worldwide and strengthen
Health Systems ensuring Primary Health
Care for people that have no access to
it especially but not only in Africa and
Asia this funding will bolster the
efforts of key Partners here today
UNICEF and World Health Organization who
each play key roles in the
implementation of vaccination campaigns
and disease
surveillance you can count on us at the
IB to build together Innovative and
ambitious Financial schemes going
forward we can face Global challenges
leveraging our respective strengths we
can tackle underinvestment for
fundamental human development
initiatives and today I feel feel more
confident than ever to say we can
eradicate polio thank you very
much thank you Mr Hoya I now invite Dr
tedos gesus director general of the
World Health Organization
I think after uh many of the
speakers after urula and uh bill and
wner I would say I endorse this
everything that they have said and go
but I'll will say a few words so I hope
you will bear with me if I repeat some
of the things they have
said your Excellency president UL
underline uh Bill Gates co-chair of the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation UNICEF
executive director Katherine Russell
European Investment Bank and my good
friend president ver ho excellencies
estimate members of the media dear
colleagues and
Friends when the global po eradication
initiative was established in 198 8
there were an estimated 350,000 cases a
year I think Bill had described this in
a different way as well so far this year
just three cases of wild poo virus have
been reported in one area of Pakistan
and six in one area of
Afghanistan we stand on the threshold of
making polio only the second human
disease in history to be
eradicated but
if we are to do that we must reach the
hardest to reach children in the most
marginalized
communities it's therefore an honor to
be here today for the announcement of
this Innovative financing mechanism
which aims to do just that with 1.1
billion euros in funding for health
including 500 million e for polio
eradication I thank the European
commission the European Investment Bank
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
and our sister agency UNICEF for coming
to together to join in this life saving
project we can only eradicate polio if
we
vaccinate each and every child children
who are unvaccinated or only partially
vaccinated typically live in remote
areas
in communities with little access to
health services this new financing
mechanism will allow us to reach those
children this agreement goes beyond
polio to deliver vital Health Services
to children in remote and marginalized
communities including misiles vaccines
and other routin
immunizations the new funding will also
be used to strengthen systems to better
prepare and respond to emerging Health
threats with dis like coid 19 and Ebola
I again thank our partners for coming
together to help build more sustainable
and resilient Health Systems among the
world's most vulnerable populations to
help us along the paths of universal
health coverage and health for all but
especially today's main purpose to
eradicate polium and I join ver in
saying we can end polio this is the
final push and we can do it but we
should keep pushing and I would like to
join also bill in appreciating Verner
for his leadership as you wrapping up
and um still I know the passion your
passion in the eradication of polio
although you're retiring you will be
changing a tire to finish polio thank
you thank you so
much
thank you finally I invite Mrs Katherine
Russell executive director of
Unicef thank you very much and good
afternoon it's really great to be here
with you this is such an exciting day
and I think this partnership is a great
example of what we can do when we all
come together as you've heard polio
eradication is finally Within Reach
thanks to the tremendous generosity of
our partners and their support for the
heroic efforts of health workers and
Community influencers around the world
but the progress we've made against this
disease is fragile and we cannot afford
to relent in our efforts for most of us
polio evokes long ago images of Iron
lungs and children Embraces but for some
children the possibility of a lifetime
of paralysis or even death is very very
real and that is true even though we
have had the vaccine to prevent it for
decades millions of children are still
missing out on this vaccination and
that's for a host of reasons pandemic
related disruptions conflict climate
disasters displacement and increasing
vaccine
misinformation most of these children as
Dr tedro said live in the poorest and
most marginalized communities with
limited access to life-saving
vaccination and Health Services
these are the places where the Insidious
polio virus continues to thrive and to
spread the funding Announcement by the
partnership today will be critical to
our efforts to finally vaccinate all of
these children against polio and it will
support the strengthening of
community-based Health Systems including
community health workers who are on the
front lines every single day ultimately
this effort can help ensure Primary
Health Care for every child everywhere
there are so many forces in this world
that debilitate maim or kill children as
hard as we try and we try very hard at
UNICEF we cannot prevent all of them but
we can prevent polio and if we can we
must thank you very
much thank you very much to all of our
speakers this now concludes our launch
event thank you for having joined us
[Applause]
today my friend come
on